[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis sûr que certains d'entre vous et
surtout certaines se sont déjà demandé
pourquoi il y avait plus souvent la
queue devant les toilettes des femmes
que devant celles des hommes bon ça
s'explique par des tas de facteurs
le fait qu'on ait 52% de la population
mais aussi pour des raisons
physiologiques
elles ont leurs règles elles ont des
vessies plus petit et puis elle
accompagne aussi encore majoritairement
les personnes qui ont besoin des deux
les enfants et les personnes âgées les
personnes âgées qui elles mêmes sont
majoritairement des femmes
mais il ya aussi un facteur spatiale à
ce phénomène
en vérité les toilettes sont comme une
incarnation des inégalités de genre
fêtes espace la manière dont on les
conçoit et dont on les construit ça
reflète des valeurs de genre quand on
regarde dans les espaces publics
aujourd'hui il ya encore beaucoup plus
du riz noir par exemple que de toilettes
à 6
sasa présuppose entre guillemets que les
femmes vont plutôt passé dans les
espaces publics plutôt que se les
approprier de manière réelle je sais pas
si vous avez entendu parler il ya un
mois il ya eu une polémique à amsterdam
parce qu'il ya un juge qui a attribué
une amende à une femme qui avait uriné
dans la rue il lui avait expliqué que
même si c'était pas super pratique
elle aurait quand même pu utiliser les
urinoirs du coup du coup les féministes
jeune irlandaise n'était pas super
contente et elle ont compté le nombre de
toilettes publiques amsterdam 35
urinoirs pour trois toilettes publiques
à 6 ce problème on peut aussi le croiser
avec d'autres discriminations comme
l'âge le handicap ou l'origine peut-être
que vous avez vu le film les figures de
l'ombre qui est sorti cette année qui
raconte l'histoire de catherine johnson
une femme afro-américaine qui
travaillait la nasa dans les années 60
il ya une scène récurrente dans ce film
on la voit courir d'un bout à l'autre de
la base de la nasa pour trouver des
toilettes parce que dans son bâtiment
y a pas de toilettes pour femmes noires
et ça ça incarne vraiment le système
inégalitaire de cette époque dans ce
milieu professionnel là qui est à la
fois extrêmement blanc est extrêmement
masculin pourtant dans les espaces
urbanisés et très densément urbanisées
les toilettes sont une des
infrastructures les plus indispensables
pour satisfaire nos besoins fondamentaux
évidemment si on restreint l'accès à des
toilettes à une partie de la population
ça veut dire qu'on bloque ses capacités
de déplacement de loisirs de travail par
rapport aux à la partie de la population
qui elle a accès à des toilettes
pourtant dans mes recherches quand
j'interroge des professionnels des
architectes des urbanistes
une phrase que j'entends extrêmement
souvent c'est mais nous on discrimine
personne on aménage pour tout le monde
c'est comme si ces inégalités de genre
était totalement invisible à leurs yeux
parce qu'en fait ils ont ils et elles
n'ont pas du tout l'habitude de prendre
en compte les inégalités de genre en
compte dans leur travail quotidien
parce que dès les formations en fait on
n'en parle pas du tout de ces questions
là on a l'habitude de parler par exemple
des inégalités de classe sociale
en lisant des ouvrages très classique
comme celui d'henri lefebvre le droit à
la ville on critique aussi l'urbanisme
sécuritaire contre les personnes qui
vivent dans la rue et puis on fait un
petit peu allusion aux questions
d'accessibilité pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite en étudiant les lois
qui qui sont destinés à leur rendre
accessible le tout l'espace public
on apprend aussi une des définitions une
des définitions de l'urbanisme qui est
l'organisation spatiale des villes ce
qui présuppose qu'une autorité fasse des
choix selon certaines valeurs pourtant
selon qui composent cette autorité en
fait surtout quand les 13 homogène d'un
point de vue social on se rend compte
qu'il ya certaines parties de la
population qui vont être avantagés et
d'autres qui vont être plutôt
discriminés et jusqu'à récemment on l'a
déjà vu ce milieu de l'architecturé de
l'urbanisme était extrêmement masculin
il ya aussi extrêmement peu quand on
regarde dans la théorie l'urbanisme
extrêmement peu de femmes qui sont
étudiées et quand elles deux sont elles
sont extrêmement contemporaine peut
penser à françoise choay ou à jane
jacobs et là je vous parle même pas de
la culture et de la connaissance
féministes ou des études de genre parce
que ça c'est pas du tout intégré de
manière générale en fait dans ces
formations là moi même j'ai dû faire en
fait le lien entre les deux et ça se
fait un peu par hasard c'était c'était
en 2011 qu un an après que je commence
mes études d'urbanisme et j'étais en
train de chercher un sujet de recherche
mais ce n'était pas vraiment passionné
par des sujets classiques comme le
logement social les infrastructures de
transport ou les évolutions de la
propriété foncière
parallèlement je découvrais les milieux
féministes et la littérature féministe
et c'est cette année là que j'ai que
j'ai lu pour la première fois simone de
beauvoir et son deuxième sexe et sa
éveillé été publiés 60 ans avant ma
lecture plus de 60 ans à un mollet avant
ma lecture mais pourtant ça faisait
vraiment écho à mon expérience
quotidienne en tant que personne
sociabiliser comme une femme cette
lecture là elle m'a autant révolté que
libéré en quelque sorte
et tout à coup j'ai eu une espèce d'idée
comme ça de me dire ah mais en fait il
faudrait que je fasse de l'urbanisme et
du féminisme en même temps et j'ai
commencé à faire une petite recherche
est tout de suite je suis tombé sur
montréal et son programme fans' ville du
coup j'ai décidé d'aller faire mon
premier terrain de recherches là-bas
pendant quelques mois
est ce que j'ai découvert là bas c'est
vraiment hyper intéressant le programme
femmes et villes il a été développé au
début des années 90 dans l'objectif
d'intégrer les femmes à tous les âges
toutes les échelles de décision autant
citoyenne qu'administrative et politique
dans les décisions d'urbanisme et du
coup il ya eu toutes les années
suivantes pendant une dizaine d'années
une quinzaine d'années il ya eu
énormément de travail qui a été fait en
partant de la base et a dans tous les
quartiers de montréal les femmes ont
fait des marches exploratoires des
groupes de femmes de jour comme de nuit
et les informations qu'elles ont récolté
ont été permis de produire des documents
en direction des services d'urbanisme et
du coup il ya plein d espaces qui ont
été réaménagés comme des parc dé
stationnement souterrain des stations de
métro
parallèlement il ya une féminisation
aussi du milieu administratif et
technique de l'organisme et puis aussi
une prise de pouvoir de plus de femmes
dans les lieux de décisions en 1996 il
ya eu ce système qui a été mis en place
qui s'appelle entre deux arrêts et c'est
un système qui permet aux femmes qui
voyagent seuls le soir dans le bus de
demandes est de demander à ce qu'on
s'arrête entre deux arrêts histoire
d'être déposés plus proche de chez elle
ce système là ils fonctionnent encore
aujourd'hui plus de vingt ans plus tard
il est extrêmement populaire et il n'est
pas seulement utilisée par des femmes
d'ailleurs tout ce travail là qui a été
fait depuis des décennies à montréal et
dans d'autres villes du canada comme
toronto et dans d'autres villes des
états unis d'australie aussi des villes
européennes auxquelles on a déjà fait
allusion comme viennent mais aussi
berlin barcelone londres et également
des pays en voie de développement comme
l'inde ou le mexique
les professionnels de l'urbanisme en
france ne prenne en compte ces questions
là
comparé aux décennies de travail dans
d'autres pays que depuis quelques années
et ça c'est mon sujet de recherche
actuels d'un sujet de thèse j'essaie de
comprendre pourquoi cette prise en
compte du genre est aussi tardive chez
les professionnels de l'urbanisme en
france
j'essaye de comprendre quels sont les
facteurs qui encouragent cette prise en
compte ou qui le décourage ou qui le
freine alors j'ai plusieurs pistes à
partager avec vous
la première c'est le manque de
légitimité de connaissance de la
connaissance féministes des études de
genre dans ce domaine pourtant il ya
beaucoup de littérature qui existe mais
elle est très méconnue il ya des
centaines de références en anglais mais
aussi en français qui existe est
d'ailleurs moi j'ai créé un outil en
ligne bibliographie en ligne que tout le
monde
on peut consulter ou ya des centaines de
références disponibles
la deuxième hypothèse où pistes de
recherche c'est la posture de neutralité
que les que les professionnels à adopte
en général c'est un peu comme s'ils
considéraient ils et elles considéraient
qu'ils étaient des personnes neutres
totalement rationnelle et que leur
expérience personnelle l'influencé pas
du tout leurs décisions professionnelles
ça c'est la connaissance situé en fait
et le troisième point c'est plus d'un
pendu de la démographie du milieu
professionnel
l'hypothèse c'est que plus il y plus il
ya de femmes dans ce milieu mais aussi
de personnes lgbt i q c'est à dire
lesbienne gay bisexuelle transgenre
queer intersexe mais aussi de personnes
féministe plus les intérêts de tous ces
groupes peuvent être intégrés dans le
travail quotidien et mieux mieux prises
en compte
alors une fois qu'on sait poser toutes
ses questions et qu'on intègre plus de
diversité dans la réflexion quelles
solutions on peut trouver par exemple
pour les toilettes
si je reprends l'exemple du départ
aujourd'hui quand on ne conçoit des
toilettes hommes et femmes ont fait du
50 50 en terme de surface or on a vu que
les femmes ont plus souvent aux
toilettes qu'on est plus nombreuse et
puis que les systèmes à s'y prennent
aussi plus de place par rapport aux yeux
noirs par exemple donc forcément ça
explique en grande partie la question de
là que parce qu'il ya moins de stations
disponibles pour la même surface donc
peut-être qu'on pourrait penser
simplement à faire une répartition un
peu plus équitable de la surface 60 40
70 30
par exemple on pourrait aussi se dire
que c'est important d'éviter ce genre de
problème ça a été fait à l'aéroport
d'orly en 2013 alors peut-être qu'on
pourrait éviter en tant que
professionnel de reproduire des
stéréotypes de genre et encourager
meilleure répartition des tâches de
reproduction c'est assez important
on pourrait même aller plus loin quand
même par rapport à lass est question de
la binarité hommes femmes
on peut aller plus loin que ça en
proposant par exemple systématiquement
des toilettes neutre que les personnes
qui ne se considèrent comme faisant
partie d'aucune des deux catégories
catégorie hommes ou femmes c'est à dire
les personnes intersexes les personnes
non binaire les personnes trans qui
subissent beaucoup de violence dans ces
espaces là elle pourrait utiliser des
toilettes neutre en toute tranquillité
d'esprit en toute sécurité
peut-être que dans le futur on ira même
jusqu'à des genres est complètement les
espaces de toilette par exemple lancé
par an seulement
seulement selon la fonctionnalité
c'est-à-dire assis ou debout
sachant qu'il ya aussi des designers
actuellement qui cherchent des façons de
faire totalement alternatif des
toilettes bon pour en revenir à un point
de vue un peu plus générale en tant que
professionnels de l'urbanisme et de
l'architecturé
c'est sûr qu'on ne peut pas obliger les
gens à utiliser les espaces de telle ou
telle manière
mais ça n'empêche pas qu'on puisse quand
même se demander quelles évolutions
sociétales on a envie d'accompagner ça
ça passe dans une approche réflexive
ça veut dire qu'on va essayer de
comprendre quelles sont nos bières en
tant qu'individu et en tant que
collectif de professionnels pour trouver
de meilleures solutions vraiment
inclusive
donc ça veut dire qu'on va se poser des
questions comme voilà quels sont mes
billets en tant que personne de telle ou
telle origine telle ou telle classe
sociale de tel ou tel genre est ce que
j'ai tendance à oublier certaines
catégories de la population
est-ce que je peux qu'est-ce que je peux
faire dans ce cas là pour rééquilibrer
cet oubli est surtout bac l évolution
sociétale j'ai envie de l'accompagner
dans le temps une fois qu'on s'est posé
ces questions là on peut commencer à
faire les choses d'une autre manière
d'une manière nouvelle et plus inclusive
et moi je suis persuadé que ces
questions que vous soyez urbanistes
architectes ou quel que soit votre
métier vous pouvez aussi vous
vous les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]